hast du einen kleinen süßen erzählt was
wirklich sache ist
bis 7 ob ich nicht und du wirst es auch
nicht werden können meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren herzen kommen zum
zweiten teil der reaktion auf eine
absolut legendäre und wertvolle folge
von hilft mir im ersten teil war
deprimiert zu gast wir haben gesehen wie
ein 24 jähriger familienvater mit kind
seine frau betrügt indem er sie selbst
prostituiert
wir haben gesehen dass er einem
wunderbaren ort arbeitet in denen die
menschen absolut normal angezogen sind
ganz wichtig natürlich auch noch er lebt
mit seiner frau und seinem kind auf gar
keinen fall in dem garten aus und
brandaktuell am ende der ersten folge
wir gesehen wie er aber einer grunde zu
hause ist ein hausbesuch quasi macht
strecken wieder ein
ja genau das war ja ebenso die situation
also er hat sich aus irgendeinem grund
gerade eben die hose wieder angezogen
obwohl er dann nichts mit ihr gemacht
hat scheinbar aber trotzdem keine hose
an warum keine ahnung und ich muss sagen
man kann sich eigentlich wirklich
beschweren er hat einfach dafür dass er
nichts gemacht hat einfach mal zwei euro
bekommt man einfach nichts gemacht er
hat gesagt dass er kein bock hat also
keinen bock hat
es darf ich kann jetzt nicht gleich nein
nein jetzt auf lass es doch sein
[Musik]
das kann es eigentlich auch nicht sein
oder
es kann eigentlich nicht mal auf youtube
sein dass uns so eine schauspielerische
fehlleistung angeboten wer dahinter
folgen die lektüre sogar ersten beiden
schüsse bis nötiger passiert nix danach
berührte er sie so ganz leicht so mit
den fingern und sie lukrativ sicher
[Applaus]
hätte ich denke da der richtige
schauspieler bei euch zu den ist süß ist
falsch er fragt wieso die größte
schwalbe legt sich hin glück gehabt dass
ich nicht geld dafür bekommen hat kein
recht ein wenig plätze 30 dabei so das t
shirt vom leib
warum das passt überhaupt nicht zusammen
[Applaus]
schade an der stelle dass wir jetzt hier
kein beitrag von einem der
qualifizierten rechtsanwälte von rtl2
bekommen das hat zu wissen ob es auch
noch als körperverletzung zählt wenn man
sich erst 30 und später fallen lässt ich
musste länger machen sorry war der vater
ist nicht dabei toll
natürlich ist der vater nicht dabei der
vater musste sich halt erst mal
prostituierten so denkt doch ein
bisschen nach seinem einstieg vor allem
dass er diverse andere dann auf jeden
fall habe ich verstehe es zu zeiten bei
seite steckt derzeit in den rucksack
gelegt einer der sichersten orte um geld
auch zu bewahren also ich bin jetzt
wirklich weiß ich eben leute aber wenn
er genauso schlecht colruyt wie er lügt
dann hat ein problem
auch ganz ehrlich das ist auch nicht so
die art und weise wie glücksspiel
funktioniert jux spiel funktioniert
nicht so dass man spielt und dann mehr
als ein glück funktioniert so dass man
spielt und weniger geld hat in den
allermeisten fällen
mal ganz davon abgesehen leute erinnern
wird wahrscheinlich ich habe im letzten
video die theorie aufgestellt dass sie
in dem gartenhaus wohnen
es war wirklich so ich glaube wirklich
dass dominique feiner kerl ist und dass
er möchte dass es seinen lieben gut geht
aber was er nicht sieht ist dass es
denen gerade richtig schlecht geht
insbesondere dominiques frau ja ich bin
ich kann sich was ich davon halte so
leute er ist angeblich ein guter kerl
geht aber seine frau mit anderen frauen
fremd und kriegt auch noch geld dafür
dass er seine frau mit anderen frauen
beträgt die wunde auf dem campingplatz
haben noch nicht mal ein richtiges
zuhause also er hat auch nichts gelernt
er arbeitet in einer bar
was zur hölle ist nach oben ohne alter
vor allem mal ganz kurz zum thema oben
ohne hier sehen wir nämlich anfangs
ihnen von diesem video und die frau ist
hätte er nicht so ohne dies eher oben
mit kleineren ich habe immer gesagt sie
soll ihn nicht heiraten diesem versage
dominique
[Musik]
der leider nix
er lernt einfach nichts entwickelt sich
zuhause antritt sollte ich dann
irgendwann seine beziehung zu seiner
frau zu arbeiten geht es direkt wieder
in die oben ohne war
warum hat jetzt einen russischen akzent
hat er sich jetzt auch vor russischen
omas spezialisiert das sollte es auch
hier drüben ist die bahn dazwischen
zeitlosen vor anja vorhang und da machte
dann ein geschäft
es ist wirklich einfach nur ein vorhaben
meter breit ist und wahrscheinlich zwei
zentimeter dünn man da nicht irgendwas
sehr professionell von dem ich war das
ganz anders machen
so spürt hier auch so ein leichtes
ekelgefühle in euch so hoch steigen
[Musik]
vor allem leute das ist die frau die
eben einfach so eine krasse schweife ab
gezogen hat und damit sogar zur polizei
gehen wollte solange die dafür nicht
ihre gelbe karte kassiert hat mache ich
spiele ja auch nicht mit die frau soll
die frau ist auf jeden fall auch die
einzige person die in dieser gesamten
konstellationen die in dieser folge zu
sehen dass ihre ist männer die halbnackt
nur in hosenträger und fliege an der bar
arbeiten vollkommen normal was du hier
haben sie besucht kennengelernt
irgendwas sagt mir dass das jetzt die
blonde frau ist mit der er geschäftlich
schon was hatte ich will darauf dass sie
es nicht ist aber ich glaube es ist okay
[Musik]
unterwegs hat das eigene kind zum
spielen da hingebracht und lernen
irgendeine andere frau erkennen so 30
kunden vergeben die andere frau so
müssen die haare schneiden und dann
diese ja es war so klar ich muss sagen
dass wir wirklich packt oder dazu
beiträgt dass man wirklich eine eher
magere erfahrung hat wie man sieht mir
folgen anschaut es gibt wirklich in der
ganzen folge vier schauspieler für alles
so ok das ist wieder ein ganz klarer
fall von spielplatz business die hälte
folge zu hallo die mutter so hallo frau
so wollen sie meine haare schneiden bei
der putzen die mutter so im alltag auf
deutschen spielplätzen wie gesagt
nein sie sind frauen erzählt was
wirklich sache ist hab ich gesehen hab
ich gar nicht und du wirst es auch nicht
werden können
diese ältere frauen die gib mir wirklich
gekriegt kern seite wenn die habe ich
jetzt verlässt sie ist doch alles was
ich habe
wissen was mir gerade gedacht habe diese
folge geht einfach so zu ende ich glaub
als erwartet einfach auch niemand was
besseres kann das sein so man schaut so
13 minuten hilft mir nun wir müssen sie
jetzt nicht erzählen wie das ist das was
jeder für sich selbst und die folge an
sich sind einfach so stumpf gemacht es
gibt einfach keinen das einfach dreist
so die folgen haben auch youtube einfach
kein ende
im fernsehen schauen wir schon auf
youtube nicht stört früh gewarnt
ich glaube ganz ehrlich leute sagen ja
froh wenn ihr versucht ist was lernen
wir aus dieser falle leute ganz einfach
wenn ihr selbst callboys zeit mit
kindern oder ihr befreundete callboys
wird kinder darf dann dann habt ihr
eingeschossen
das war so weiter hat hier drückt so
einen für euch vorgeschlagen das video
vielen dank fürs zuhören bis hierhin ich
könnt eure augen